calico basin is a popular recreation
area which includes a large part of red
rock
the bureau of land management wants to
manage that area better
those plans include figuring out how to
implement a fee collection program
take care of the trails and improve
facilities and that includes bathrooms
and parking lots
the bureau of land management also wants
to make sure the public is informed
about the area
something climbers agree with
i think a huge issue is a lot of people
that visit calico basin
are uneducated about leave no trace
so um i think a great thing for the area
would be to
really push to educate people on leave
no trace and
the importance of packing out trash and
waste and
making that a front and center issue
so pretty with all that snow out there
remember when it looked like that
last night happened about a week into
a 30-day information gathering period
it started a virtual meeting involving
the general public
is set for thursday i believe that was
last night's meeting
anyway we'll give you more on that in
our on our website 8newsnow.com